so I actually wrote down some notes oh
good good I should I'm glad you wrote
some stuff down because I want to ask
you question and I don't know if it's
okay for interrupting sure you know what
they call when they sing - nothing
acapella right that's pretty good that I
got something right yeah doesn't happen
that often for me okay let me ask you
know those if comedy I know but what was
Disney's follow-up to the Little Mermaid
oh I had no idea I think it was Aladdin
Wow just called make God feel stupid
know if it's a new game you guys you're
trying to watch happy give me a heads up
is that how high you are right now let's
let's talk about this the bringer show I
wish I would have been able to like do
you have to pronounce it that way
bringer the bringers the bring Hirsch
the bringer show bringer bringer he said
that he didn't know what a bringer show
was I don't know Todd I don't believe
either of them really can I say
something else I saw this little please
when they people when they both here we
go tell me I'm being honest - we're all
on the table honest as it can get
here it is you know I take these cases
seriously you it's just a big joke
mundanes big lou and away 300 pow my
favorite season Templar do more all the
ones with short round pulling out you
want to figure out this case and put a
little time into it where you have it
well do have you made your decision I
don't even know what case were judging
the guy saying it's the other girls I
guess jazz clothes to be a bringer show
is it but I don't know why he would have
the number $500 in his head if she's
like because if it's a bringer show make
her house yesterday half of what you're
supposed to pay yeah see Todd how not so
hard is it
[Music]